[Music]
critics are calling the batman the best
dc movie in years but how does it stack
up against the mcu keep watching for how
it beats most marvel movies at the
superhero movie game warning some
spoilers ahead
with a few noteworthy exceptions like
wakanda and black panther and some of
its intergalactic locales the mcu
generally doesn't have a huge emphasis
on its settings this is in part because
the mcu is essentially the same as our
world just with super beings mr musk
how are you congratulations on the
promotion thank you very much
this is a fine strategy for making your
stories feel real without spending a lot
of time on world building allowing
viewers to fill in the blanks based on
their own experiences christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy utilized the
strategy as well simply treating gotham
as if it were chicago new york or
whatever real city the movies were
filming in but it's world building where
the batman excels most of all it's
gotham is a marvel of production design
as gothic as tim burton's version but
less cartoony a lot of thought was put
into not just how this distinctive city
looks but how it feels what it's like to
live there and why this corrupted place
needs batman in the first place a sense
of place in the batman not only exceeds
the majority of the mcu but much of the
superhero movie genre as a whole
the mcu mostly sticks to a formula with
minor variations marvel might talk up
captain america the winter soldier as a
political thriller ant-man as a heist
movie eternals as a philosophical drama
and so on but despite these different
flavors these movies generally end up in
the same place as action movies building
toward a cgi filled third act battle
when warner brothers hyped the batman as
a neo-noir detective film however the
studio actually gave us what they were
selling there are still the action
scenes you expect from a superhero movie
but there are far fewer of them than
most of its contemporaries the vast
majority of the three-hour run time is
spent investigating crime scenes
interrogating suspects and struggling to
uncover conspiracies critics aren't
kidding when they've compared it to the
crime thrillers of david fincher it has
more in common structurally with a film
like seven or zodiac than with the
avengers or even the dark knight oh
you're really not as smart as i thought
you were
though the marvel films have their
moments of beauty the studio's
insistence on a consistent house style
has resulted in some pretty bland
visuals even when the technical skill on
display in these movies is impressive
critics say the general aesthetic is
washed out and sometimes flat out ugly
this is absolutely not the case with the
batman which ranks among the most
visually stunning blockbusters in recent
memory shot by greg fraser the
cinematographer who earned oscar
nominations for 2016's lion and 2021's
june the batman is a cinematographic
achievement that deserved to be
remembered come awards season filming a
movie set almost entirely at night and
in the shadows is a challenge but fraser
keeps the images clear and beautiful
even when the darkness is overwhelming
the batman is particularly inventive
with light sources using everything from
gunfire to the engines of the batmobile
as substitutes for traditional lighting
this might not be the most even grounds
for comparison because to date marvel
movies generally aren't trying to be
scary doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness directed by sam raimi might
change all that as such it's no slight
on the mcu to say that the batman is
significantly scarier than anything the
mcu has attempted thus far and it is yet
another thing matt reeves film excels at
the riddler's grotesque killings push
the limits of the pg-13 rating to the
extreme if anything the restraint in the
film shows to avoid r-rated content
makes what's implied all the more
disturbing from ticking bombs to topical
political nightmares to one of the most
startingly believable depictions of near
future climate disaster there are
multiple sequences in the batman that
could haunt your nightmares needless to
say think twice before letting the kids
watch
this is also something of an apples to
oranges comparison because the mcu
special effects spend a lot of time
depicting things significantly less real
than anything in the batman even with
that in mind however marvel studios can
be inconsistent regarding special
effects
some stuff looks great but there are
many questionable moments of rushed or
lower quality effects in otherwise high
quality movies in terms of consistent
realism the batman beats basically every
marvel movie when it comes to special
effects some of the special effects in
the batman look real because they are
real the batmobile driving through fire
is a real practical stunt however
there's also a lot of cgi used so
seamlessly in the film that most viewers
won't even be aware certain shots are
effects shots the batman makes extensive
use of ilm stagecraft system previously
used on the mandalorian which combines
projections with virtual reality
technology to allow for the most
realistic cinematography of cgi
backgrounds
let's be fair and acknowledge that
marvel studios has gotten a lot better
at villains from phase 3 of the mcu
onward vulture killmonger and thanos or
standout antagonists and among the most
interesting parts of their respective
movies in its first two phases however
the mcu had a major villain problem with
no one aside from loki and ultron
providing much in the way of
entertainment or interesting
personalities the focus was on
developing a wide range of heroes with
their enemies being an afterthought the
batman has three major villains the
riddler the penguin and carmine falcone
and they're all superior to the non-loki
villains of the mcu phases one and two
take it easy
paul dano's riddler is the most
significant villain in moving the plot
along and he's also the scariest but he
still has complex motives for why he's
committing his horrible crimes calling
farrell's penguin is a fun gangster
character ready for his spin-off show
and john turturro's falcone uses menace
as the villain with the most personal
connection to the wayne family
the mcu is exceptional at what it does
in terms of building an interconnected
franchise where audiences feel they have
to see everything even the films that do
work as standalone stories are designed
with cool backs and future teasers in
mind between the epic conclusion of the
infinity saga and the multiverse
adventures in phase 4 the mcu has only
grown more confident in its viewers
familiarity with past movies and in the
case of spider-man no way home movies
that weren't even part of the mcu this
is all well and good but we can't
dismiss the value of a well-told
self-contained story that doesn't feel
like it's putting off any important
narrative or character development for
sequels the batman might be the start of
a cinematic universe of its own with
sequels and hbo max spin-offs on the way
but it's successful as a complete story
only one particular scene feels a bit
too marvelous in terms of playing like a
blatant sequel tease but director matt
reeves told variety that's not actually
the case check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]